Listening to the debate,
uh, it is clear that the allegations against MEPs Genoka,
that she provided far ranging assistance
to Russian intelligence services,
came as no surprise to anyone in this hemicycle.
And of course,
there is multiple evidence of Russian interference, uh,
throughout this European Parliament,
and it set out in multiple reports. And, yes,
no one has been more aligned to MEPs Danoka
than the two Irish MEPs of independence for change.
They try to brush it off as guilt by association,
but they travelled with her
to defend the Lithuanian diplomat
convicted of spying for Russia.
With only 11 other Meps,
they voted not to condemn Russia
after the invasion of Ukraine.
They posed for photographs
and attended webinars with her.
So why is it not legitimate to ask,
did you have your suspicions?
Or are you so naive
that you didn't have any suspicions at all?
What a shame it is that Ireland elects MEPs
making excuses for Kremlin aggression
and Putin's relentless campaign
to undermine European elections.